Taron Egerton colin firth and mark
strong team up with their American
counterparts of statesmen in the
superspy sequel Kings win the Golden
Circle UPK movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm going to reveal some
behind the scenes facts Easter eggs and
on set secrets about the second Kings
were movie
I'm also kicking off a new giveaway so
for a chance to win this fantastic Kings
were merchandise make sure you're
subscribed to my channel and leave a
comment about the movie below to bring
to life the villainous character of
poppy Adams who's head of the Golden
Circle criminal organization actress
Julianne Moore and director Matthew
Vaughn took inspiration from some
intriguing places including the 1978
Superman movie Julianne Moore especially
loved the way that gene Hackman's Lex
Luthor and Valerie pariahs miss
Tessmacher spoke to each other like
regular people despite all their super
villainy and decided to channel that
feeling for her performance as poppy as
with the design of poppy land which is
Poppy's Americana inspired leur set in
an ancient ruin in Southeast Asia
Matthew Vaughn went for a full on Martha
Stewart vibe mixed with Vegas and
Disneyland because as Bourne says poppy
is America's Sweetheart gone very wrong
speaking of poppy land when actor Keith
Allen who plays one of Poppy's minions
and the movie found out that the set for
Poppy's diner was going to be thrown
away once filming was finished he
decided to rescue it so with the
producers permission allen had the set
loaded onto a truck and transported to
stroud in Gloucestershire where much of
it now features in an American style
diner run by his wife Elton John
certainly has some memorable scenes in
the Golden Circle
however he actually turned down a part
in the first Kings were movie that would
have shown him throwing tantrums and
getting in a big fight in fact the
original script for Kingsman the Secret
Service included a whole series of
cameos by celebrities who were going to
show up when they were abducted by
samuel l.jackson villain Valentine but
the idea of celebrities actually
appearing in the film as themselves was
scrapped as director Matthew Vaughn was
turned down by the celebrities he
approached by the way look out for
various Elton John Easter eggs during
the movie including nods to his songs
and albums on the marquee at Poppy's
theatre and Poppy's robodog's they even
named Benny and Jett after John's hit
song Benny and the Jets plus Elton
John's cameo and
sequal also includes an innuendo Laden
callback to a controversial joke from
the first kings were movie on the
subject of that divisive gag at the end
of the Secret Service
Matthew Vaughn and co-screenwriter Jane
Goldman have included an equally
contentious moment in the sequel which
shows eggsy planting a tracking device
on a character named clora
played by poppy Delevigne sister
valerian star Cara Delevigne the scene
features an intimate moment that Taron
Egerton told screen rants he was not
comfortable with so instead of the hand
which appears in that scene being edgy
turns it's actually the hand of poppy
the Levine's real-life husband James
Kirk and apparently Matthew Vaughn makes
an effort to include such controversy
courting moments in his movies speaking
to Total Film he stated that it was
Stanley Kubrick who said you need five
water cooler moments and then you've got
a hit film so I always try to put 8 in
to make sure at least five happen for
example the finger seen in this one I
know it's gonna people are gonna talk
about it whether and it'll be a divided
opinion but there will be an opinion by
the way I mentioned earlier the
controversial ending of the first King's
birth film well Vaughan has also
confessed to Deadline calm as he made
the first cut of that scene a lot more
graphic on purpose and he was
deliberately trying to wind up Emma
Watts 20th Century Fox's president of
production although he also admitted he
completely failed in his efforts to do
this spending days tied to mechanical
bull to film a scene as secret agent
whisky was not acted Pedro Pascal's idea
of a good time especially as he's had
tons of back problems since playing
Oberyn Martell in Game of Thrones but
after four days in the saddle at least
the scene was in the can or so Pascal
thought that is until he got a phone
call months after the movie wrapped from
Matthew Vaughn who dropped the bombshell
that he cut the entire mechanical bull
scene from the movie while Kowloon first
Kingsman character Harry Hart was
inspired by British actor David Niven
and Michael Caine's fictional spy Harry
Palmer in movies such as the Ipcress
files
Pedro Pascal's character agent whisky
who's part of the Statesmen American
intelligence agency is based on a mix of
the Marlboro Man and actors James Coburn
and Burt Reynolds and to bring the
Statesmen leader champagne aka champ to
life Jeff Bridges drew our memories
acta father Lloyd Bridges as well as its
previous cowboy roles including Wild
Bill Hickok when it came to the
character of eggsy though it was Luke
Skywalker's journey over the course of
the original Star Wars trilogy that
really struck a chord with Matthew
Vaughn and he kept that in mind when he
was outlining eggsy's journey in the
golden circle and as the golden circle
is the first sequel that Vaughn as
directed he revisited some of his
favorite cinematic sequels such as The
Godfather Part 2 aliens and the Empire
Strikes Back for inspiration if you
think that punch in the face that
Charlie gives eggsy during their brawl
looked pretty painful that's because it
was Edie Holcroft who plays the rejected
Kingsman applicant turned villain
Charlie misjudged the angle and ended up
smashing his friend Kingsman star Taron
Egerton in the face with the full force
of his thump landing right on Edgerton
Snow's obviously Edgerton was pretty
annoyed at the time but the filmmakers
thought it looks so good they decided to
use that take in the final movie and
that was an adjutant only onset injury
while filming the Kingsmen sequel during
a break between takes he was sat on top
of the taxi they were using for a stunt
sequence when a member of the crew
walked past and slammed the cab door
shut not realizing that Edgerton hand
was in the way ouch the action scene
featuring that taxi cab includes a nod
to the 1977 movie The Spy Who Loved Me
which stars Roger Moore as James Bond in
that film bond escapes the baddies by
putting his Lotus Esprit car into
submersible mode and going underwater
Kingsman director Matthew Vaughn loved
that scene and wanted to recreate the
moment but in a much more attainable car
for people watching in the audience
hence the taxi cab and talking of bond
did you notice the bottled in Bond mark
on the Statesmen liquor that Merlin and
eggsy find in the vault bottled in bond
as a term used in the American drinks
industry that means the whiskey has been
made to a certain standard but
coincidentally it's also a nice wink to
the fact that the Kingsmen movies are a
great debt to the Bond films now what
did you think of Kingsman the Golden
Circle how did it compare to the first
film and what were your best and worst
moments let me know in the comments
below and also don't forget to subscribe
for your chance to win some awesome
Kingsman merch
I'll announce the winner on an upcoming
video so turn on your notifications to
make sure you catch it if you enjoyed
this don't forget to hit the thumbs up
button and check out some more videos
you might like hear the winner of my
Thor Ragnarok pop giveaway is on the
screen right now so if that's you send
me a message with your details and I'll
get the prize sent out to you thanks for
watching and see you next time you be
going with me lovers